good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight one upside of the very
sad war in ukraine is the national
conversation underway in this country
about freedom and democracy those are
words on everyone's lips and so it set
us off on a nationwide search for
americans who are living as if this were
a free country like it was say 1989
and one of the first people we found we
have to tell you was kid rock we spent
the weekend with him we've got an
interview with him in just a moment
but first time what exactly is democracy
well pluralism is the hallmark of it in
a democracy citizens can have any
opinion they want to have they can
express any opinion they want in public
whenever they care to express it
including through mass media if citizens
are dissatisfied with their political
leadership they can challenge their
leaders for office
now all of these things are true in
every free country in any period always
these are not just features of democracy
these are prerequisites for democracy
so with that in mind you should know
about a political party in ukraine
called opposition platform for life with
43 seats in parliament it is the largest
opposition party in that country
over the weekend the president of
ukraine floyd mirzelenski banned that
party opposition platform for life is
now prohibited from quote all activity
within ukraine so with a single command
zlensky made it impossible for anybody
to run against him for president
he did this not just to opposition
platform for life but to 10 other
political parties that he believed were
insufficiently loyal to him they're all
illegal now obviously there's a war
underway in ukraine and on that basis
zielinski has declared martial law but
we must tell you there is no evidence
that the opposition parties he banned
were aiding russia in its war against
ukraine opposition platform for life for
example denounced the russian invasion
the moment it happened just like
everybody else
but zielinski took the opportunity to
turn ukraine into effectively a
one-party state which it now is so
having banned all opposition he then
seized control of the country's media
outlets zielinski signed a decree that
combines all national television
channels into a single platform that he
controls he described this as a quote
unified information policy and it
certainly is unified
so if all these details seem shocking to
you if this is not the zelinski you've
heard about on the today show then you
may not have been paying attention to
ukraine
zielinski has been solidifying complete
control over ukraine for a long time
since long before the russian invasion
and the war
last year he had his main political
opponent arrested and his assets seized
by the state
at the same time zielinski shut down
three of ukraine's most popular
television networks channels that not
coincidentally had criticized him
so how should we as americans assess
this well first most obviously by
admitting this is authoritarianism it's
not democracy
and then second by acknowledging that
actually it's pretty common around the
world even in 2022 real democracy is a
rare thing anywhere most countries are
still governed by some variety of
dictatorship whatever they may call it
and that includes close american allies
the kingdoms of jordan and saudi arabia
come to mind but there are others
we're not moralizing about this by the
way obviously we'd prefer democracy
everywhere in every country but as
americans it's probably a waste of time
to get too involved in the internal
affairs of other countries they're hard
to change
what we care about what all americans
should care about is what happens here
in the united states the united states
is
despite the fact it's also a bumper
sticker doesn't make it untrue is a
beacon of hope and freedom to the rest
of the world
how do we maintain that inspiring
position not simply by sending people
missiles
but by remaining free ourselves the
united states cannot be a beacon of
freedom of light in the world if we are
not free
so that's the first thing we do if we
want to inspire and change the world
ukraine included
is make sure that we stay free
and with that concern in mind you should
be very worried by your leaders response
to what's happening in ukraine the
growing dictatorship there and that's
the word for it what's another word for
it
if you have ideas send it to us
on the very same day that zelinski shut
down opposition media and all opposition
political parties professional liar and
atlantic magazine pundit david frum
posted this on twitter verbatim quote
ukraine may be the first example in
human history of a country that under
the pressure of war is becoming more
tolerant and more liberal
right
so when you outlaw all criticism of
yourself that's called tolerance it's
called democracy
but don't take the word of a single
canadian warmonger propagandist david
frum is hardly alone in telling you that
all of washington is telling you that
watch
so proud of president zielinski and the
courage that he has shown
and in congress we are trying to get the
administration on board president biden
is showing moral leadership just like
president zelinski's showing more
leadership he of course by his example
shows the kind of courage we all hope we
can reach and and provide at a moment of
real testing government doesn't give us
our rights our rights come to us from
god and government is just a shared tool
to secure them and you see that spirit
that american
philadelphia 1787 spirit in zilinski
so the man who just declared himself
king is actually the world's newest
george washington okay so you can be
deeply concerned and deeply saddened
outraged by what's happening to
ukrainians without saying things like
that
because it's absurd it's a lie
that's the word from senator ben sasse
of nebraska a republican and again on
one level you can understand why people
are whipped into an emotional frenzy
when they talk about ukraine why
wouldn't they be russia's invasion of
ukraine was shocking it was wrong the
suffering of civilians there is entirely
real we're watching it on tv it's
horrifying
so it's entirely natural to root for the
ukrainians to expel the invaders and
obviously we are rooting for them to
expel the invaders russia
but just because what russia has done in
ukraine was wrong
doesn't mean you have to lie about the
ukrainian government in fact if you
really cared about the ukrainian people
and all the people you saw on tv we care
so much
you wouldn't want them to live under a
dictator so you'd be highly upset about
what zelinski just did
but our leaders are not upset in the
slightest they're cheering it on even
when they know better so someone they're
just too dumb to know but some of them
do know michael mcfaul for example he's
barack obama's ambassador to russia
unlike shallow gas bags like dick durbin
or ben sasse mcfaul actually understands
eastern europe he has lived there he
knows exactly who zielinski is and
exactly what he's doing
so here's his assessment of the
ukrainian government not the people the
government as of this afternoon quote if
zelinski remains in power ukrainian
democracy is preserved
that guy teaches at stanford
but that's not true
so again ukraine was invaded by its
neighbors and we oppose that we should
oppose that but that doesn't mean
ukraine is a democracy it's not and we
shouldn't tell americans it is because
that's a lie we should tell the truth
but virtually no one is telling the
truth everyone is lying so why why is
everyone lying why not just say look
it's outrageous that russia did this and
we're gonna we like ukraine better
we're gonna support ukraine fine
why go the extra step to tell us that
ukraine is a model democracy when it's
not at all
why are they doing that
maybe because ukraine now has exactly
the sort of democracy they'd like to see
here in the united states
they hate to think that could be true
it's scary to think that's true but ask
yourself play this word game if they
could find a quote national security
pretext for it a war for example
do you think adam schiff and kamala
harris or mitch mcconnell would pause
for even a second before banning their
political opponents for running from
office in this country do you think they
would hesitate before pulling this show
off the air forever
no of course not they do it in a flash
then they call it democracy
so maybe you're starting to conclude
these people love zolensky not because
he represents the ukrainian people
but because zelensky is exactly the
leader they would like to be
with
wildly expanded war powers to make
everyone who complains shut up at
gunpoint
maybe that's what's going on it seems
kind of obvious when you think about it
now of course we pray they never have
the power to do any of that in this
country the last free country in the
world we should not let them do that
because freedom in america is not just
important to us our children and
grandchildren it's important to the
globe again we are the last free country
we must
remain free
but in the meantime a war is being waged
in america's name with our money so it's
fair to ask how the side we are backing
is doing clearly there are an awful lot
of heroic ukrainian citizens we see them
all the time on television we applaud
them we admire them
but how's the government doing how is it
behaving again we have a right to know
even if state control media in ukraine
won't report it even if our sort of
state-controlled media here downplays it
dismisses it
here's a man called kennedy drizenko
trusenko is a medic in charge of a field
hospital in ukraine he's appeared on cnn
in this clip he casually announces that
he has ordered the castration of
captured russian soldiers
[Music]
foreign
cockroaches not people now again that
doesn't mean the broader ukrainian
causes unjust it is just they were
invaded they have a right to fight back
and expel the russians from their
country and for the fifth time we're
rooting for that
but we're paying for this so we have a
right to know exactly what's happening
we have an absolute right to know in
fact we have a constitutional right to
free media we don't have that that video
by the way disappeared
people on the internet managed to get a
copy of it you may hear it dismissed as
russian propaganda just like 100 laptop
was or the 2016 presidential election
results in this country were but it's
not russian propaganda it's real the man
you just saw speaking has confirmed the
video is authentic he apologized for it
so murdering pows is a war crime so it's
castrating them we're not shocked by
this this happens that a lot of
countries ukraine is not unique
atrocities happen during war every war
always no matter what the neocons may
tell you
but this is a war that we are paying for
this is a war with moral implications
this is a war the white house is
involved in at every level so when the
ukrainian government does something we
have an interest in knowing exactly what
it is and what it means but more than
anything we have no overriding interest
any moral obligation to keep the united
states free so when you see them admire
someone who's shutting down any
opposition to him
you should pause hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else